meeting with prime minister Lim
so let me start with the EU China
relations
it is an extensive and complex
relationship that we have
for both of us this relationship has a
significant impact on our prosperity and
our and our security for China because
the European Union is the first export
destination
while China is in the European Union the
third export destination if I give you
one concrete figure this means trade of
more than 2.3 billion euros per day in
2022.
at the same time our trade relationship
is increasingly imbalanced
so over the last 10 years the European
Union straight deficit has become more
than has more than tripled
it reached almost 400 billion euros last
year
and we discussed that because this
trajectory is not sustainable and the
underlying structural issues need to be
addressed
I conveyed that European union
businesses in China are concerned by
unfair practices in some sectors
um unfair practices that impede their
access to the Chinese market for example
if you take the EU agri-food products
they face significant hurdles or if you
take medical devices as an example they
are being excluded from the market by
discriminatory by China policies all of
these sectors I'm speaking about are
recognized areas of European excellence
so these sectoral issues are exacerbated
by ever-growing requirements imposed by
China that apply across the board
be it for example increasing pressure to
submit technology transfer albeit
excessive data requirements orbit and so
forth insufficient enforcement of
intellectual property rights
all this puts European Union companies
exporting to China
and also those producing in China in a
significant disadvantage we discussed
that and we discussed also the fact that
this contrast contrasts with the Level
Playing Field that all companies
operating in the European single Market
benefit from
so against this backdrop the European
Union is coming more and more Vigilant
about protecting our interests and
ensuring a Level Playing Field
in addition to these imbalances in our
relationship as you know the European
Union is growing more Vigilant about
dependencies
some of these dependencies raise
significant risks for us as does the
export of sensitive emerging
Technologies
within this context a con test we all
know that
this leads to calls by some
to decouple from China I doubt that this
is a viable or desirable strategy
I believe that we have to engage in
de-risking this means focusing on
specific risks
while appreciating that there is of
course a large majorities of goods and
services so trade that is unrisky
of course different risks required
different means to address them
we address the risk of dependencies
through the diversification of our trade
and investment relations
and the risk of leakage of sensitive
technologies that could be used for
military purposes needs to be addressed
through export controls or investment
screening
but whatever the instrument we chose is
we wish to solve the current issues
through dialogue so it's basically
de-risking through diplomacy
and this is why I called for and we
agreed in the resumption of the
high-level economic and trade dialogue
I'm very glad that we agreed on this
not only the high-level economic and
trade dialogue but along with this one
also the digital high level dialogue
these two dialogues should convene as
soon as possible to make progress on all
the different files and produce tangible
results
let me now turn to the geopolitical
environment
this visit is taking place in a
challenging and increasing volatile
context
in particular
because of Russia's war of aggression
against Ukraine
China's position on this is crucial for
the European Union
as a member of the U.N security Council
there is a big responsibility
and we expect that China will play its
role
and promote a just peace one that
respects Ukraine's sovereignty and
territorial Integrity one of the
cornerstones of the U.N Charter
I did emphasize in our talks today that
I stand firmly behind president
zielinski's peace plan
I also welcomed some of the principles
that have been put forward by China
this is notably the case on the issue of
nuclear safety and risk reduction
and China's statement on the
unacceptability of nuclear threats or
the use of nuclear weapons
we also count
on China not to provide any military
equipment directly or indirectly to
Russia because we all know arming the
aggressor would be against international
law and it would significantly harm our
relationship
we also addressed human rights
I expressed our deep concerns about the
deterioration of the human rights
situation in China
the situation in Xin Yang is
particularly concerning it is important
that we continue to discuss these issues
and I therefore welcome that we have
already resumed the EU China human
rights dialogue
besides Russia's invasion of Ukraine
there are some areas of convergence and
cooperation on specific Global issues
and in view of the size of our economies
we have a shared responsibility in
resolving Global issues
for example first and foremost to
promote the climate and to protect the
climate and to protect our environment
I particularly welcome the positive role
that China has played in delivering the
Montreal Kunming agreement on
biodiversity
China has also been a driving force to
reach a deal on the high sea treaty
this is particularly positive
so on the fight against climate change
we want to see China make concrete and
ambitious commitments in the run-up for
cop 28 in Dubai we'll discussed this
topic too and I invited China
to jointly prepare this cop 28 in the
context of our joint initiative with
Canada
and of course I would very much welcome
if China would be choosing to join the
global missing pledge we need China as
an important player so these were the
different topics in general that we have
discussed and I'm now looking forward to
answer your questions
thank you thank you
to Russia
and then yesterday you were still
together
really that I thank you smooth and I
would literally keep every country on
Earth
and my question is
do you think that Chinese government
learning interested from West Africa
so um
indeed I as I reported raised the point
of arms deliveries and I want to be very
clear on that one that arming the
aggressor is a clear violation of
international law it's the aggressor and
he should never be armed and this would
indeed significantly harm the
relationship between the European Union
and China
on your second question
um we all agree that stability in the
Taiwan Strait is of Paramount importance
we have a very clear interest in
preserving this stability the peace
and the status quo in the Taiwan Strait
and therefore nobody should unilateral
unilaterally change the status quo by
force in this region
the threat to or the use of force to
change the status for is unacceptable
and it is important that certain the
tensions that might occur should be
resolved through dialogue
and we have discussed these topics too
so both topics have been raised
for the foreign
factors in happening in our in our
bilateral relationship between you and
China so I'm wondering during this
during the important meeting in hell
today do you have any opportunity to
explain or interpret the journey in
Pursuit and the national principle of EU
strategy partner EU strategic attorney
to your Chinese yeah since
at least two years we are very clear on
our
open strategic autonomy
this is a discussion that started during
the pandemic and when we
felt the knock-on effects of
several regions worldwide that shut down
export of vital
Goods that were necessary to fight the
pandemic not the European Union we
discussed the open strategic autonomy in
such a way that we said it is very clear
for us that we stay open we exported up
to today 3.5 billion doses of vaccines
so this is a large number and we were
the only produce vaccine producing
region worldwide that never closed the
Border but kept exporting while we also
were very Vigilant to export as much as
we delivered to the European people
but we felt like many other regions of
the world that with the breakdown of for
example Supply chains how vulnerable we
were
the second element
where the Strategic autonomy was being
felt heavily by the necessity for the
Strategic autonomy was being felt
heavily by the European Union was with
Russia's war of aggression against
Ukraine
as you know
just a year ago
there was a strong dependency of the
European Union on Russian fossil fuels
um and Russia used this dependency to
Blackmail us on the field of energy
by cutting 80 percent of the pipeline
gas supplied to the European Union
within eight months
this triggered
a
severe energy crisis but we were able to
withstand
and we were able to show that we do not
give in to the blackmail on the contrary
we completely diversify the way
from Russian fossil fuels we invested
massively in renewable energy
that are homegrown and contribute to our
European security
and Independence but of course also to
protect the climate and the European
people saved about 20 percent
of their energy demand
and these are two examples that show
that we want
with an open strategic autonomy
in a very clear European individual
European way independent and sovereign
to Define where we see risks there we
have to address them where we need to
strengthen our supply chains for example
where we need to diversify our supply
chains and where we have to improve our
position
the New York Times
[Music]
do you believe that China is trying to
drive a wedge between Europe and the
United States
the transatlantic bonds
are strong and founded on trust
and a deep friendship
since decades
and I was just referring
to the critical situation we were in
last year with cutting energy
the cuts of Russian gas supply
it were our friends like for example the
United States that immediately stepped
in with increasing the deliveries of LNG
so
the transatlantic bonds are strong and
they are based on friendship but they
are also based on shared values
and this is a very important part that
is unshakable
um
then
we discussed
and I raised the topic I encouraged
president XI to reach out to president
zelenski
I know from my phone calls that and
president zelenski asked for it publicly
so it was interesting to hear that
president XI reiterated his willingness
to speak when conditions and time are
right I think this is a positive element
there was a third component in your
question which I forgot
I must admit no okay thank you
it's late
um
would like to Google like to know that
if a person she gave a clear timeline to
call your current president of the
currency and the second question is you
mentioned about the importance to local
corresponding risking rather than
recovery if you release this
presidency and emergency responsibility
yes I think on the first question I just
uh said well gave the answer on the
second question indeed it was very
important for me to discuss with
President XI and of course also with
prime minister Lee
um that we think that de-risking is
important not decoupling
and
um with both I discussed uh different
examples where we see for example that
deer risking is necessary
we also discussed I must always put that
in the same context the other side of
the coin that is for us the imbalances
we see in the trade between
the European Union and China
but
one factor of discussion was indeed that
de-risking
is to be seen in the context that there
are many goods and services in trade
that are unrisky
here the imbalances play a role so we
have to address them but there are some
Goods that we see where we see that we
have to de-risk and that this is
something we want to address and
therefore it's so important to have this
high level economic and trade dialogue
to address specifically there are
specific asks from many companies from
the European Union very concrete cases
and this cannot be tackled in a
leaders meeting but it can it has to be
tackled in a high-level meeting and high
level dialogue and we want to address
that directly
thank you very much
nope
sorry okay uh
it is the question about did you raise
with you back on the insurance
[Music]
we know that we're entering and trying
to be met they made a statement against
the idea of uh
[Music]
give you on this
and more generally how do you interpret
the fact that Mr XI went to Moscow just
a few weeks ago so we offering support
one here at the queen what does that
mean that actually
the relationship within China and Russia
is far more uh and shakeable like you
are trying to give to them
um I've raised uh indeed the topic in
general of the nuclear nuclear arms
threats and specifically also our deep
concern
what uh the nuclear arms threats
potentially based in or stationed in
Belarus are concerned so I was very
clear on both
um I think it is also visible in public
statements in the peace
plan that China put forward and yeah in
public statements that China is strongly
advocating against using not only using
nuclear weapons but also not even using
the threat of nuclear weapons and this
is a point where we absolutely agree
on that one
now you were
asking about different meetings
um
China being a permanent member of the
United Nations security Council
has a big responsibility
to use
its influence
in a
friendship that is built on decades
with Russia
and we count on China
to really exert also this responsibility
and to be very clear in the messaging
uh
Investments
today and Instagram is dead or alive
and the secondly just if you could just
clarify exactly what roles you receive
from China playing
in the planning the resolution to
conference
well I think I outlined strongly the
responsibility that China has we all
have our responsibility each and
everyone in his or her place
but China
knowing Russia well
and being a permanent member of the UN
Security Council has also a very
distinct responsibility to use its
inference on China for positive
development
the comprehensive agreement on
investment did not come up
um you know our position
we started the negotiations around about
10 years ago and we concluded at the
comprehensive agreement on investment
around about two years ago a lot has
happened since then the whole discussion
that we have tonight here mirrors that
so
we have seen also during that time a for
the deterioration of the market access I
was describing of European companies in
the Chinese market
so the lack of Level Playing Field that
we need so our position is that we do
have to reassess
the comprehensive agreement on
investment
s the end of this press conference thank
you very much thank you
[Music]